Hi friends, welcome to this channel. We
praise God for devoted servant of God
like the pastor Randy Skit who explains
Bible clearly as it's supposed to be.
During a Q&A session, this young man
asked Pastor Randy Skit a question all
of us might have about how to have
devotions during the day and how does he
have devotions? He shares his secrets on
how to have devotions and our weekend
too in these last days to be connected
with God. Now let us watch this video.
>> God bless you. Let's go to the side.
>> How do you have devotions?
>> How?
>> Yeah. Like what do you do?
>> You know, this is odd. I have devotions
all day. Well, I start in the morning.
Yes. You know, but all day. What do I
mean by that?
I um I'm always on the road going to
supermarket or wherever
and I'm always reciting Bible verses and
thinking what does this say? What does
this mean? Trying to make connection
between one passage and another passage.
I'm literally always doing it. When I
say always, I don't mean 24 hours a day,
every minute. I mean at least every
hour, part of the hour, I'm going
through uh passages either reviewing or
trying to learn new passages. And I'm
thinking a few questions. What does this
tell me about Jesus?
Because they are they which testify of
me. What does this verse teach me about
Christ, the love of God? What does it
teach me about righteousness? The
central teaching of the gospel,
righteousness by faith, what Christ does
for the sinner. What how does it help me
understand some other passage?
And as you recite and you learn and you
fill your head, it's easy to compare
this verse with that verse and that
verse with this verse. And so literally
all during the day when I'm in the gym,
you won't believe this, but I'll tell
you. Let's say you're on the bench
press, you do a set, 10 reps, and you
take a minute to recover you.
I said to my That's a waste of time.
Just sit there.
Let me recite a verse. In the beginning,
God created the heaven. So I started
literally reciting passages while I'm
recovering. So what I would do, I would
time some passages, usually the Psalms.
I would lift up my eyes into the hills
from all or Revelation 15 and see, okay,
this takes 40 seconds. I'll say it
twice. And I do that so that the time is
used. You understand what I'm trying to
say? And so I uh that my devotion begins
in the morning, but it also goes during
the day. You'll ask my wife, she'll tell
you this, as I go to the darkest part of
the house, turn off all the lights and
sit on the floor
and uh just start thinking of a turn off
all the lights so you have no
distractions, no nothing. Think of a
Bible verse. Think on it. What does this
say, Father? Just dwell on it. Dwell on
it. Dwell on it. Something else I do
that's devotional.
I've I'm trying to connect everything to
the Bible. For instance, let's say I'm
wearing a linen shirt or cotton shirt.
Where does cotton come from? A plant.
When were plants made? On the third day.
Am I right or am I wrong? Yes. And so
you make a connection immediately
between your shirt and creation. Are you
with me? Was it sunny today?
>> It is still sunny. When was the sun
made?
On day four. Who is the son of
righteousness? Jesus Christ. You make
that spiritual connection. Have you ever
driven down the street and you saw a
dead deer, a dead rabbit, a dead
something? We call it roadkill.
How did death enter the world? Sin.
Because the curse of Adam affected not
only Adam, Elise said his rebellion
passed to the animal kingdom. And so
they die. And so you you a bird flies
by. They were made on the fifth day. One
day I too will fly through the
atmosphere. What I'm saying to tell you,
try to make a spiritual connection with
every single. If you do that, your mind
is so constantly employed with that
which is spiritual. The devil is always
having to wait, wait until she thinks
about a rock song. Wait until he starts
rapping, then I can come in.
Keep the mind on the You see a human
being, they were made on the sixth day.
As by one man sin entered into the world
and death by sin Christ became human.
You have a fight with your mother or
your father.
Didn't Lucifer have a fight with his
creator Jesus Christ? Yes. Every single
thing.
What is the spiritual connection? And in
classroom, what's the spiritual
connection in the classroom? Don't
pursue a grade first. Pursue a deeper
knowledge of God. Now, you didn't get
what I said. Let me say it again. I'm
not telling you don't care what grade
you get because I earlier said
excellence God requires. I'm saying to
you is let your pursuit of a grade
travel on the track of your pursuit of a
deeper knowledge of God.
>> If you're studying biology, who created
life?
>> Why do you hesitate? Who created life?
God. Now you ask yourself, where is God
in this cell? Where is God in anorobic
respiration? Where is God in gaseous
exchange in the lungs? Because every
creator, every artist leaves his or her
fingerprints. If you're a musician, you
can listen to music and say that's
Mozart or that's Handel. You look at a
painting, that's Michelangelo or that's
whomever or that's Picasso. It's the
same with God. Isaiah 6:3, the whole
earth is full of his glory. Psalm 19:1,
the heavens declare the glory of God.
And so all of the heaven the glory of
God, all of the earth the glory of God
despite pollution. You look for God in
accounting. Didn't he arrange the
tithing system offering your Mhm.
everything you study? Eli says whatever
line of investigation we pursue with a
sincere knowledge to arrive at truth, we
are brought into communion with that
mighty unseen intelligence because all
legitimate knowledge flows from God. I
said legitimate crime is not a
legitimate knowledge. It did not
originate with God. All branches of
legitimate knowledge from accounting to
zoology originate with God. And so what
I'm telling you, pursue a deeper
knowledge of God. And if you do it, the
grade will come. It changes your
motivation. But the outcome is the same
because God sees now she's looking for
me in this physics class. He's looking
for me in this math class. She's looking
for me in this history class. I'm a god
of prophecy and the Lord will bless your
efforts. Search for a deeper knowledge
of God. The great will come.
Amen.